y hoy 12 de junio es el Día Mundial
contra el trabajo infantil Y aunque
durante 20 años se logró reducir
progresivamente la cantidad de menores
de edad que eran sometidos a trabajar en
los años de la pandemia y las crisis
económicas posteriores esta cifra volvió
a aumentar la organización Internacional
del trabajo Calcula que casi uno de cada
10 niños y niñas trabajan actualmente y
para hablar del tema conectamos ahora
con Pilar Rodríguez ella es coordinadora
de la secretaría técnica de la
iniciativa regional América Latina y el
Caribe libre de trabajo infantil Pilar
Muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros en France 24 Le agradezco mucho
su presencia
Hola buenos días Gracias Pilar le
empiezo planteando se ha hablado mucho
de las consecuencias de la pandemia pero
cuáles fueron sus efectos en la pobreza
infantil y como esto forzó a más a
menores de edad a trabajar
lógicamente la falta de empleo y de
cierre de negocios dificultó pues la
capacidad de las familias para
satisfacer necesidades básicas no
durante la pandemia pues incluso de
vivienda atención médica etcétera
entonces la propia necesidad de generar
ingresos para ayudar a sus familias Pues
muchas niñas y niños se vieron obligados
a trabajar no a trabajar en condiciones
peligrosas incluso explotadoras
está en el fondo la falta de
oportunidades de las personas adultas es
los que empujan a los niños y a las
niñas a los menores a asumir este
responsabilidades laborales no que no
deberían ser asumidas a su edad pero
también es importante destacar que el
trabajo infantil no solo es el resultado
de la pandemia ya existía antes de la
crisis sanitaria la pandemia la crisis
encadenadas que vamos sufriendo lo que
ha hecho es incrementar esto a
exacerbado no las desigualdades y ha
dejado a muchas familias que estaban en
situación económica desesperada Pues a
que de alguna manera sus niños y sus
niñas vayan a trabajar no
es importante saber que si nosotros
queremos terminar con esta lacra es un
esfuerzo de todos de todas de toda la
sociedad la sociedad no se pueden
permitir tener a niñas y niños
trabajando y precisamente en estos
esfuerzos de toda la sociedad a los que
usted apunta cuál Debería ser el papel
de las autoridades cuando Pues los
progenitores o las personas que están a
cargo de los menores no tienen un lugar
una escuela o un jardín de infancia
donde dejarlos y el trabajo es un poco
una consecuencia de esta falta de
alternativas
si lógicamente la el trabajo infantil es
la cara visible de
dificultades estructurales que tienen
los propios países la responsabilidad
por supuestísimo de los gobiernos de
cuidar a su población pasa por tener
ofrecer elementos básicos como buena
protección social como
atención escolar escuela de calidad
trabajo decente para las para todas las
personas sobre todo para las personas
adultas atender la economía del cuidado
donde muchas madres están trabajando de
una manera sin remunerar para que luego
para poder sobrevivir Y de alguna manera
llevar sustento a la familia un de otra
manera hacer visible todo lo que es el
trabajo doméstico por ejemplo no donde
muchas niñas y niñas adolescentes
trabajan cuando son trabajos que se
están considerando riesgos y peligrosos
las autoridades
en la obligación que le da el propio
estado por ser
autoridades en sí misma de hacer cumplir
que de proteger los derechos de todas
las personas especialmente la de los
niños y niñas más vulnerable trabajar en
coordinación trabajar a nivel local
trabajar ahí donde están los problemas
desde este ámbito nosotros desde la
iniciativa regional contribuimos con los
estados con los gobiernos las
organizaciones de trabajadores y de
empleadores para poder identificar
aquellos lugares que son más
susceptibles de tener trabajo infantil e
intentar cortar esa trayectoria porque
indudablemente trabajamos duramente en
la prevención en las causas
estructurales Porque de nada sirve ir
retirando a niños y a niñas de trabajo
Si siguen entrando otros nuevos
imagínate no le preguntó Pilar Cuáles
son las consecuencias tanto para el
menor en términos individuales como para
toda la sociedad el hecho de que pues la
mayoría de sus niños o parte de sus
niños estén explotados laboralmente
Sí bueno indudablemente para para desde
el punto de vista individual de los
niños imagínate no la mayoría de los
niños y niñas que trabajan tienen que
abandonar la escuela esto supone no
solamente que estos chicos y chicas
estén haciendo o llevando a cabo una
actividad laboral sino además que se
interrumpa esa trayectoria que le va Le
va a permitir crecer a lo largo de la
vida y ir mejorando en esos puestos de
trabajo y en ese tipo de trabajo y
afectan a su salud
pensemos que los niños y las niñas están
expuestos a situaciones riesgosas de
trabajos peligrosos Por ejemplo si
trabajan en la agricultura
pesticidas a instrumentos peligrosos
donde de alguna manera pueden verse
afectado y como no También trabajas
también influye en el desarrollo a nivel
amplio y en el desarrollo económico de
los propios países porque no tengamos en
cuenta que una población de personas
jóvenes niños niñas adolescentes que
están trabajando y que no pueden o que
no han podido
ampliar sus competencias
indudablemente repercute en el en el
tejido productivo del país cuánto
talento no se está perdiendo porque son
niños o niñas estén trabajando en La
Fragua estén trabajando en una mina
estamos viendo las imágenes de niñas y
niños trabajando en el campo cuánto
talento no pierde un país no pierde una
nación porque haya niños y niñas que
estén trabajando y Pilar rápidamente
usted mencionaba el caso de las minas
Pero hay muchos casos de empresas
transnacionales que se aprovechan de
esta explotación infantil Cómo abordar
esta situación Cómo frenarlo
Bueno es es una situación muy compleja
hace unos minutos estaba oyendo al
Premio Nobel de la Paz El señor kailache
que denunciaba esto no indudablemente
muchas empresas multinacionales
transnacionales
en el producto que ellos derivan no no
Aparentemente no existe trabajo infantil
Entonces ahora mismo estamos trabajando
muy duro sobre toda la producción de las
cadenas de suministro el señor kaylas
hoy ponía un ejemplo por ejemplo
nosotros ahora hablamos de energía
limpia de coches eléctricos pero
muchas personas no saben que que la mina
donde sale ese el cobalto necesario para
montar esos coches eléctricos en muchos
sitios en África y trabajo infantil no
entonces realmente cómo trabajamos
entre todos de manera conjunto para
atender todo lo que es la cadena de
suministro y sobre todo aquellos niveles
primarios donde se extrae materia prima
ya hablando en a nivel extractivo de
minas o en la agricultura donde se
concentran la mayoría de trabajo
infantil pues Pilar Muchísimas gracias
por haber estado con nosotros aquí en
France 24 le agradecemos mucho que nos
haya compartido su conocimiento su
análisis
Muchas gracias solamente Dame 30
segundos para invitar a todas las
personas que los niños las niñas están
ahí tienen rostros tienen papá y mamá
los padres y las madres Todos queremos
para nuestros hijos que vayan a la
escuela que sean felices Que disfruten
que jueguen fútbol que jueguen voley
Entonces no miremos hacia otro lado no
normalicemos el trabajo infantil el
trabajo infantil tiene que ser el
radicado gracias gracias a usted Pilar
ustedes sigan con nosotros
[Música]